اداره عمل مشترك مع رفيق العمر يمكن ان
يوطط العلاقه او ينهيها كسر مورو مدربه
علاقات تقترح بعض الاستراتيجيات لانجاح
الشراكه في العمل والمنزل اولا تشجيع
بعضكما البعض بدلا من التنافس ضد بعض
الغيره ممنوعه والدعم مهم انتما تلعبان
للفريق نفسه ثانيا تحديد ادوار ومسؤوليات
كل منهما واللعب على نقاط القوه من
المفترض ان يكمل كل شخص ما ينقص الاخر
ثالثا وقت العمل عمل ووقت العائله للعائله
يجب ان تلتزم بوقت محدد يوميا يمنع بعده
الكلام عن العمل رابعا علاقتكما الشخصيه
تاتي قبل العمل اذا احتاج شريكك الى
اهتمامك كل شيء اخر يمكنه الانتظار طالما
لم يكن ملحا اخيرا حدد الاهداف كفريق واحد
طبيعي ان تختلف الرؤى المهم ان الهدف واحد
على كل حال سال الناس من السعوديه ما دور
الشريك في تحقيق النجاح الوظيفي نتابع
الاجابات
دور الشريك تحقيق النجاح الوظيفي انه
احيانا يكون او غالبا يكون سبورت او دعم
للمراه اذا كان هو شخص ناجح ومحفز لها
يعني في الحياه بس عموما هو لازم يكون
عندها هيئه اساسا بذره او حاجه يعني بسيطه
وهو يكمل يساعدها هنا يكبر الدور اكثر
والله
شوف شريكه اكيد انه بيكون دورها كبير يعني
اولا بدايه من المنزل يعني ودعم الرجل
وسبل الراحه اللي يلقاها في البيت هذا
الشيء بيكون انعكاس عليه في عمله فهذا دور
كبير وبرضو ما ننسى دور الرجل اللي هو
اهتمامه بالبيت
واهتمامه بالمراه وهالشيء انا اعتقد انه
متكامل
الدور اساسي الشريك اساسي معك يعني
ارتياح في ترتيب الشو اسمه في الحياه
كامله نمط الحياه كامله مشاركه حتى في
تنسيق العمل تمام
واجبات البيت تمام
مناقشات في جميع الامور يعني لمتابعتي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات